well here we are the bad guys  you know uh just behind that door  i must go alone oh why i cannot involve  you in this  it wouldn't be right i mean i've been  pretty involved so far like  ever since we left the village i cannot  risk losing you  i got stabbed like three times already  you were fine then this is my burden i  have to bear  i can still help it's just me and the  burden you don't understand  what if i just stand there in case you  need anything this is my burden okay  shut the [ __ ] up  what i said shut up all right we're  gonna go kill this guy together come on  come on okay see  we did it just like i said i still could  have done it alone  probably but it would have been like  twice as hard  so which one of us is  going to take the credit for this  probably both of us  oh cool cool is that okay with you yeah  yeah i mean  it's it's not what the prophecy said but  um  yeah it's it's cool  you